[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma était devant nous on
a aujourd'hui des jolis jolis jolis
petits poissons du poisson pas cher il
faut se reprocher et jolie excès de
poids sont très bons et ce sont des nids
sort bine alors les sardines tout le
monde on a mangé on les a mangés à lui
sur l'eau si on a peu de chance on les a
mangés grillé au bord de la place et
s'ils doivent ou à peine d'amendé
quand on est toutes amoureuses en
attendant c'est très bon et alors
comment peut-on les faire autres n'ont
rien fait d'autre manière que vous allez
nous montrer aujourd'hui
oui j'ai vu aujourd'hui on va lui faire
une tarte aux syndicats mais novice et
ben voila mais vous allez découvrir le
plaisir apprend est alors une seconde
race est peut-être sur l'instant oui
alors après on va faire des sardines
farcies au sein des sardines plus hardis
et alors commençons par la perte
qu'est-ce qui nous faudra pour la tarte
pour la peur d'une foule bien entendu
des sardines du poivron rouge du vert
les tomates de l'oignon du citron
un joli petit immeuble du basilic de
live est terminé et avec tout ça on va
commencer par la tap
exactement comment procède-t-on c'est
très facile on commencera début par le
légume bien entendu alors les légumes en
gros y'a devons-nous l'oignon de l'ail
des poivrons de couleurs et des
tromperies renforts et des tomates dont
alors pourquoi alors là je vais l'oignon
dans l'huile d'olive chaude saison après
là il n'est pas là pour rien
non là je vais l'écraser plus de vous
voilà avec la déroute du mondial a
devancé a330
voilà donc aujourd'hui devant vous a
préparé des petits légumes coupés tout
ça là vous allez ajouter imaginaire je
fais dans le temps s'est voulue par ces
voix la lie à wavre où vous et fort
louis les tomates en suivant leurs
offres en suivant mais voilà parce que
ceux d'essence at on a tous des tendres
et puis travail une salle c'est de cela
et je crois rue normalement la serbie
brèche et l'état français à l'effort
c'est bien on va laisser cuire tout ça
et ça va nous donner le temps de vous
occuper des services alors il avait déjà
préparé à la base nous deux
qu'est-ce qu'il s'agit de leur sert
alors que d'abord dé grossesse comme ça
on voit le sens et force de l'eau voilà
à la poubelle après on laisse pas
beaucoup plus la pelouse où ben oui
quand on va y arriver
voilà
lévis 2 vous avez l'habitude vous ne la
verrez dans l'aude est sûre vous êtes
séparé de l'eau ou au jour en car même
aujourd'hui je vais pouvoir là et à
pouvoir continuer à faire deux passes
que l'autre sans façon 3 watts et
vallées il les a des amis mais si on
peut en faire moins
la très bien ce spectacle voilà bien
lors l'avait bien laver le fond ce soit
bien propre là dedans voilà maintenant
je n'ai jamais nié les légumes c'est bon
on va les laisser encore un maniement et
ensuite on prépare à la terre les
légumes sont réduits et vous les aviez
laissées j'ai remarqué refroidi un petit
peu parce que thomas du rappeur de
saisir et passe alors qu'on avait
préparé un quizz janvier prépare est
affiché à ciboure et donc nettement
mercredi
bien sûr sur cette base la femme tout le
monde se faire représenter les oeufs de
farine de l'eau ni casse 2e dessus et
puis on y vais un peu d'huile ou du
beurre voilà quatre sa manière sa
méthode est préférable d'être simple et
chacun pense ce qui fait la meilleure
panneaux dont on ne mesure même pas en
faire deux ils se trouvent
voilà un joli profit des légumes voilà
ensuite nous en effet coupé très fins de
vindicte pour être aidé par courrier un
moment parsemez de 20
c'est ça saupoudrer les remercie déjà
pas senti bien et en faire la maligne
les sardines de la perfection voilà
alors même être desservis là on va la
vie pose disposer comme ça correspond
serré où vivent ça dit il veut après
presque un petit peu comme ça ça va
saler poivrer ça devenait bon ben on
voulait plus mais c'est bon allez-vous
logiciel très bien très bien c'est un
peu de poids on a bien chauffer le four
à l'avant saint louis un bon quart
d'heure au moins pour les maisons on le
met combien de temps encore deux minutes
un bon quart d'heure la vigne et du vin
surveiller en cours très chaud
ça nous laisse le temps de faire les
sardines farcies ce we saw pas de
sensibilité sociale des services
c'est pas la mort du petit cheval et
vous allez voir c'est par contre il faut
faire attention quand même parce que le
service s'est pas fait oui alors qu'on
lui coupe la tête
editpress elle saigne encore mieux ap au
louvre
sort avec un couteau qui coûte quand
même vous pas déchirer la malice voilà
on à vide on à vis d'un premier oui oui
après ma femme et moi on s'est pas fait
vous savez je regarde ça me paraît pas
ce n'est pas de dire que vous allez il
arrête
bien sûr que si on voit là on n'arrête
pas le progrès vous payez pas la la la
la la la coupe et surtout pas voilà il
n'est pas que c'est démarrer a fait ça
vas y je te dis va pas bien mais l'une
est bon et 10 sur 10 la droite est
beaucoup plus là que non non non non non
non non regarde voilà ma famille et bien
ça me va et maintenant il n'y a plus
qu'à faire la fin il n'y a plus qu'à
faire la france va commencer petit tweet
zhenmin poil sur le feu avec wade
domaine de l'hydraulique puisque c'est
les pois sort c'est l'huile d'olive et
après maintenant je vais mettre de
l'union a trop et leur faut à ce qu'une
sardine c'est pas gros et parcourir 1
comme sessegnon je vais y rajouter de la
coupe et des collèges et dimanche ça
bien entendu c'était une bonne personne
mais après après je suis curieuse de
savoir que je vais pin et la charge de
travail voilà c'est fait défiler
j'ai enlevé tout s'arrête c'est de la
bijouterie deçà de l'épicerie on dit que
vous allez rire oui tu es allé prendre
un petit peu et je vais les écraser ça
va ça va cuire s'est déjà tenu à faire
la passe comprenez une bouillie le
tableau par tableau non plus ne sont pas
que ça fait baisser le feu la voile à
puymoyen était préparé à cette petite
chose ne porte que c'est pour les mettre
oui je vois vous réparez de la figure
avec le double pour ne pas saper la
voile a dû faire les 6 13 ans soutient
passant par le bon bout avec l'ail
l'oignon et tout ça je lis dragueur
surveillance a bien bon on retourne tout
cela bien le mélange est encore là
original mais bon vous m'aviez parlé de
fignon écran c'est l'écran millions de
dollars en fait oui nous vous l ai dit
vous le ferez deux trois pignons écrasé
la valeur ajoutée aussi y aller
et pour finir vous qu'est ce qu'un
accord pourrait préparer là on dirait
des petits polonais qui sort de choses
et bien la croix fait tout simplement
pas marché
la fameuse un petit peu mais pas trop
quand même
et maintenant il va falloir dominant sir
les sardines et je me demande comment
vous allez faire ce pas difficile de
payer le déficit les sur vos cendres de
la fun vous avez mis une cuillerée de
farce
du côté de la tête de la galerie et
après j'ai appris cela il faut aller
délicatement menacé tout petit peu
retenu l'attention
on fait de la bijouterie de cette
émission là et voir et ça tient tous
incroyable et après ça bonjour soir je
peux fournir à des petits oiseaux avec
toutes ses marques en l'air je vais
mettre un tout petit peu d'huile d'olive
et refilé oui si je peux y arriver à
peine à peine que ça brûle pas voilà le
four et rêche et très chaud il n'ya plus
qu'à mettre le plat de dans pas
longtemps
combien diminué au début de l'année dix
minutes pour shu voilà micheline nos
deux chefs sont terminés voilà l'unité
vous avez bien travaillé réfléchi jolie
et nous avons devant nous ces deux plats
inhabituel la tarte aux sardines avec un
petit lit de légumes ou les sent bon et
et jolie ont cliqué genève et puis ces
petits trucs rigolos là ces petits
rouleaux tu es de sardines formule alors
à dix après c'est pas mal de travail à
ses jours on a envie de s'amuser rigoler
quand on dépend donc il faut être vert
ou travaux publics en effet la petite
farce est bonne ça peut te faire subir
un peu l'agrémenter d'un petit peu de
citron ou un petit peu de vinaigre pour
son roman par oui avec des effets
sonores
voilà si vous avez envie un jour de vous
de faire des choses délicates et
inhabituelle amusement et vous avez des
sardines fraîches à portée de main
amusez vous bien
bon courage et à bientôt
[Musique]